you guys obviously made a huge financial
commitment to Odell Beckham just a few
months ago are you committed to him
being here in 2019 or are you open to
trade ideas or anything with him as well
we didn't sign up the trader if that's
what you're asking me that's Dave
Kellerman addressing the question of
whether or not
Odell Beckham jr. will be traded in big
hat I love it when we can see what the
guy was doing when he's asked the
question he takes the big drink of water
and he swishes it around like mouthwash
like I why am I wasting my time even
entertaining this question but it's a
real question because remember after
they paid him he did that interview with
little Wayne next to him and are you
happy in New York that's a tough
question how is that a tough question
it's yes or no you're happier you're not
so I think circumstances have changed
and I think there is value in at least
considering what you could get for Odell
Beckham jr. and we're talking about this
obviously because yesterday in a mailbag
item that he did for the athletic Jay
Glazer was asked to make a bold
prediction for the offseason and and he
chose to answer this question he didn't
have to answer the question this is a
written column this isn't something he's
doing where he's calling in to a radio
station and they asked him for a bold
prediction he specifically hand-picked
that question because he had an answer
he wanted to give and the answer is
Odell Beckham jr. is getting traded and
of course everybody lost their minds and
that's fine but I think that there is
reason to believe that Glazer knows what
he's talking about he wouldn't have said
it if he didn't think there was
something to it he got started in the
business covering the Giants I think
there's something there isn't it's just
a sign that the offseason is here
because last year was the same thing
remember John Mara gave the interview
where he said a trade is highly unlikely
but no one is untouchable and then the
year before was right after the boat
party so it feels like you know when the
fall comes the leaves changed then the
winter the frost comes then the
offseason comes in Odell Beckham is on
the trading block quietly but he's on
the trading block well remember last
year that photo emerged of him somewhere
with like uneaten pizza and some sort of
a cigarette that may
may not have contained tobacco and
everybody lost their minds and John Mara
said oh I'm done talking about Odell
Beckham jr. that was at the league
meetings in late March he had this this
gaggle with reporters where he made it
clear he's exasperated with obj and
that's when the talk started about maybe
the Rams would try to get him maybe the
49ers would try to get him and then it
all kind of died down I think cuz the
Giants wanted too much they wanted to
first-rounders but I think now that they
they had to pay him I don't think his
contract is untradable they'd have to
take a 16 million dollar cap charge for
doing it ok fine
teams take cap hits like that all the
time I just don't think it's out of the
realm of possibility if they get what
they want they would treat him like
anybody else and no player is
untouchable you ripped the name off the
back of the Jersey and if you get enough
in trade that makes you say yeah what
we'll we'll move on from the guy I think
they would and I think at a certain
level they'd maybe like to well
especially if they're saying we're gonna
have to rebuild this whole thing the
interesting part of this is how would it
affect Eli Manning because if you're
gonna trade Odell Beckham what's the
point in bringing back Eli Manning
what's the point in having him be your
quarterback because you're essentially
saying we're not gonna go to the
playoffs next year which I don't think
anyone thinks but this is how this is
how the NFL works every team says you
know we're one or two players away from
going to the playoffs
you see worse - first all the time so
that it's kind of a bigger conversation
and where the Giants going as a full
team and what are they gonna do in the
draft I I agree that nothing is unknow
players untouchable and if you can get a
lot for Odell Beckham it's a no-brainer
but I do feel like this happens every
year and it's just it's almost it's
almost like a way to keep Odell Beckham
and check being like hey you might be
traded then again Jay Glazer does have a
lot of sources he probably talks to
Odell Beckham himself he knows a lot
about the inside and inner workings of
the New York Giants so you can't just
it's not just some random person saying
it Jay Glazer does carry he doesn't say
things just for a fact he says things
that he knows so you have to actually
you know take this is a serious rumor
and again he hand-picked that question
and hand-picked that answer and a couple
of tweets emerged in response to the
news now Odell Beckham jr. had an
interesting tweet that I can't see
because he's blocked me I still don't
know why he blocked me on Twitter but
here's what he had he had a couple of
emojis and I'm not real good at emoji
interpretation but it's a mouth with the
zipper which means I ain't saying
anything plus a smiling blushing face
that emerged after Jay Glazer said what
he had to say so look I think that
Beckham would like to get to another
team I think he'd like a change of
scenery I think he'd like to get even
more money and I think he'd like to play
for a team on the west coast and we got
that impression with that that bizarre
ESPN interview that he did last
September and he also would like a
quarterback that's gonna get him the
ball more consistently so I think that
to the extent that that Beckham would be
on board with it the answer is hell yes
yeah of course you would say hell yes
this because the Giants are a mess and
he probably wants to play some playoff
football and he probably wants to go
somewhere where he is
the guy even though he is the guy in New
York right now but yeah of course he
would I would see that he'd want to
check why do you take the money this
this is what I never understand what
guys take the money and then four months
later they want out well first of all he
hasn't said that he wants out so let's
not throw that on his feet right there
okay because that's not fair to say oh
no Beckham is demanding a trade money
okay it's a rumor so let's just be fair
with that but to answer your question I
think that that's just how pro sports
work now it's kind of similar to the NBA
guys say I'm gonna sign the contract and
if I don't like the situation I will
just say I want to go somewhere else and
they will accommodate me because if
you're a star in these leagues if you
are a star in the NFL you can't you have
the power now it's it's become more and
more players League to say you know what
I'm not happy I'm on to trade and teams
will say well what's the alternative we
can see we can keep him here where he
doesn't want to be where he could
possibly be a headache or we could trade
him and possibly get a ton of draft
capital for him for a guy who's a
superstar at the wide receiver position
I was impressed you were very
responsible and careful there to make it
clear that Odell Beckham jr. has not yet
as to be traded it makes me wonder
whether or not you're trying to get him
on pardon my take
no I'm being fair
because I think there's a difference a
what's what's amazing to me is when
people lump an entire position group or
you know the diva wide receivers all
together
Antonio Browns case and in Odell
Beckham's case are completely different
in my mind Odell Beckham is a
distraction on the field at times
because of things he does on the
sideline fighting Nets being over
emotional I think that's more of a he
doesn't know how to control his own
emotion during a game Antonio Brown by
all accounts is just a really not great
teammate and I think there's a lot of
not great teammates on the Steelers and
he's very much about himself and very
much if I don't get the credit and I
don't want to be here so I'm not gonna
put Adele back I'm an Antonio Brown in
the same category I think they're
different cases and I'd rather Rodell
Beckham that Antonio Brown right now
I've met I mentioned pardon my take
you've had Jay Glazer on there before
and you don't have to bleep him if he
says words that would otherwise have to
be bleeped he posted a tweet last night
with heavy redactions for these purposes
he wasn't happy with the reaction that
he got to his bold prediction of Odell
Beckham jr. being traded there's a lot
of work
there's more bleeps in there than non
bleeps but he wasn't happy about any of
this and I'm kind of surprised I'm gonna
call Jay at some point today I thought
about calling him last night but I
didn't want to get any of the the splash
back from whatever mood he was in if
you're gonna say these things you're
gonna have a reaction and I'm surprised
that at this point in his career Jays
not a little more thicker skin to just
let that stuff kind of roll off his back
and move on and go count his money if he
needs to well I don't think this is a
thick-skinned thing I think Jay Glazer
is just Jay Glazer like he is a very
passionate guy who says whatever he
wants you've been around him I've been
around him he will say he will speak his
mind at any moment and I he'll probably
challenge a bunch of people to get in
the Octagon with him so this didn't
surprise me no I actually if you know
Jay Glazer I don't even think this is
thin-skinned I think he's just a
passionate guy who's always looking for
a fight my take on Jay and I've told him
this and I've said this before being
around Jake Glazer is like being around
a dog that you're not quite sure whether
or not it's gonna bite you
mm-hmm yeah that's fair that's fair
that's excited yeah
it's like a wild horse and and and I
have yet to be bitten by him but I may
be after the things I've said over the
last couple of minutes so I'll stop
saying
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports